Sports has always felt like
the polar opposite of virtual reality.
One is physical and tactile,
the other is perceptual and intangible,
one is mainstream, and the
other's still pretty niche.
But more and more, they're
becoming intertwined.
I think it's time for my workout.
You seem like a natural.
Whoa!
That's a little too realistic.
Athletes, fans,
and people just trying
to get in a good workout
are discovering that the virtual world
holds new possibilities,
and companies like Meta, the
corporation behind Facebook,
are hoping they can draw new adopters
by getting physical virtually.
So we think, just generally speaking,
there's a huge application for sports
in the metaverse and in virtual reality.
And I think it's truly gonna
enhance the way that fans,
players, everyone just
experiences sports going forward.
And for the world's
most valuable leagues and teams,
can these new digital
ecosystems allow fans
to not only consume
but participate in
their favorite pastimes?
Or will they not even make
it out of the starting gate?
That virtual selfie
we saw of Mark Zuckerberg,
that's a $10 billion selfie.
That's what $10 billion buys you.
That's where the criticism's coming.
So if you wanted to think
of what is the hardest thing
we could possibly do in the metaverse,
it's probably in the area of sports today.
Oh.
Uh oh. Don't tell me I drowned the ball.
I'm as bad in here as I am in real life.
Whoa.
This is Jason Rubin,
or at least his avatar.
He's the vice president of
metaverse content at Meta,
the company formally known as Facebook.
He has a long history in games
from creating "Crash Bandicoot",
to forming the gaming studio Naughty Dog.
However, that experience hasn't translated
to virtual basketball.
Somebody in the background
is coding furiously
to make sure I don't miss at this point.
This basketball hoop
is part of Meta's "Horizon Worlds,"
a sort of digital meetup space
where you can build your avatar
and connect with others
in virtual reality,
doing everything from
work meetings, concerts,
or casual conversations
near a digital beach.
Is this the metaverse?
Are we in that right now?
Or what would you say this
is right now on the scale?
We are in the metaverse in the same way
that if you're on a webpage,
you're in the internet,
but you are not the internet, right?
It's gonna take a while for us
to build a massive metaverse
that feels like a metaverse should be
and you'll never see every corner of it.
I mean, that's part of the fun of it.
Now, the metaverse is a buzzword
we've heard a lot in the last year.
The metaverse,
the next frontier of the internet.
Big tech, big brands, big ambitions,
people and companies are pouring
hundreds of millions of dollars
into the vision of the metaverse.
That reportedly is a
place where we can all go
and hang out and do business
and pretty much live our lives,
or at least our avatars
can live their lives.
If you go back to the '80s,
there was a movie called "Tron."
Who's that guy?
That's Tron. He fights for the users.
People started to imagine,
"What would it be like if
I was inside of the arcade
or what if I was inside of the computer?"
What would happen in that world?
What kinda opportunities
would get created?
This is Ben Grossman, the CEO of Magnopus,
who worked in the VFX and
film industry for years
before starting to work on bridging
the physical and digital worlds.
The internet right now
is like a newspaper.
It's words. It's pictures.
You click on the words,
it goes to other things.
You click on the pictures,
they move into videos.
So the internet is connected pages.
What we're moving towards now
is more the way of the world
works: connected spaces.
If each of those spaces can exist
between the physical
layer that we all live in
and a completely virtual layer,
consumers will be able
to interact with content
the way that they want to, in
the context that they want to,
and probably moving towards
one universal device
that helps them do it.
Building out this new form
of navigating our digital
and physical lives
is something the largest
tech companies in the world
are dedicating vast amounts
of resources towards.
Meta, Apple, Google,
Microsoft continue to make
long-term investments
in hardware and software
to bring consumers and companies
into immersive 3D worlds.
I sound like a boomer, even
though I'm not, but I'm like,
"I'll just hang out in
the real world for now."
I am a boomer and I'm gonna say,
"I just wanna hang out in the real world."
The term metaverse is pretty problematic
because it originates in science fiction
and it's associated with a
little bit of a dystopian vision
that not everybody would
think is, you know,
something we should all be
aspiring towards building.
Unfortunately, all the
other terms that people
have come up with haven't
really taken traction,
and then courtesy of Mark
Zuckerberg's decision
to change the name of Facebook to Meta
now we have metaverse.
Starting today, our company is now Meta.
Now, we have a new North Star
to help bring the metaverse to life.
Meta has invested
billions into this space,
including reporting a $10
billion loss last year
on its virtual and augmented
reality arm Reality Labs.
This move to the metaverse
started back in 2014
with then Facebook's acquisition
of VR headset maker Oculus for $2 billion.
So they were really kind of in
a very vulnerable business position
with Google and Apple
effectively controlling
their access to most of their customers.
So Facebook needed to kind of say,
"Well, I need something that's next
that we can control in its entirety."
They would argue that that's in order
to drive a better experience,
or in order to create something
that you couldn't have done while working
through the plumbing of
the traditional internet.
I think renaming themselves
Meta is probably an indication
that they are tripling down on this idea
that the metaverse is the next big idea.
Companies like Google,
Valve, Sony, and Microsoft
have all introduced products
to the VR and AR space.
Even Apple is rumored to be
developing its own device.
Meta has been one of the
more visible companies
in this space,
aiming to create products and content,
not just for gamers, but for everyone.
However, early versions of what
the metaverse inside
those headsets look like
have not always been met with excitement.
There are larger issues here
outside of Mark Zuckerberg
posting a really weird baby-like
selfie from the metaverse
and his time on the Rogan Podcast.
It really goes down to
whether or not people
can even figure out what
they want a headset for.
If corporations want headsets
to be the next smartphones,
they're going to have
to make virtual reality
more accessible and fun.
One way to do that, sports,
even simple ones, like throwing
a basketball in a hoop.
Next time I do an
interview, rule number one,
gotta learn how to do the basketball
before you're doing it, right?
There it is.
Okay.
There it is!
Oh! There it is.
All right, now I can go home and sleep.
Yeah.
But that just gave us something to do.
Like, we're talking, right?
This is what you would do
with a friend doing something.
It doesn't have to be
basketball. It could be whatever.
But this is very different
than sitting on VC
with your hands in your lap talking.
Meta's really excited about
sports and fitness inside VR,
inside the metaverse,
for a lot of reasons,
but one of the main reasons is it tends
to be a social activity,
and VR and the metaverse
are social activities.
We're excited in a lot
of aspects of sports.
We're excited in people's ability
to see professional sports,
that they might be stuck at home alone,
you can see it with other people,
more excited about people
playing sports together,
whether it's recreations
of real-world sports
and virtual reality,
or it's new types of sports
that only exist in virtuality,
only exist in the metaverse.
And there's also aspects like training
that are starting to work now where people
are training to become baseball players
inside virtual reality,
inside the metaverse.
All right, we're ready?
Okay, watch my bun there.
Drill of the goal is to score
as many touchdowns as you can.
Show me how it goes, so
I'ma need you to show.
How many you got?
Yeah, I got the high score.
Um, alright.
So you got your play call.
Tap the break button.
Boom.
Now you got that, you're good. Hit break.
Okay, cool.
Boom, and then you gotta
find your guy and throw.
This is "NFL Pro Era,"
a newly released virtual reality game
that puts you in the helmet
of your favorite NFL quarterback.
You can select your team,
pick your favorite play,
and then just like a QB
either hand the ball
off to a running back,
find an open receiver,
or take off running, but with a joystick.
Oh, you got sacked.
Oh, dang.
You gotta get that ball out.
You gotta get the ball out.
Ball two!
The game's available on a couple headsets
and made by developer StatusPRO,
founded by former NFL wide
receiver Andrew Hawkins
and former Division 1
quarterback Troy Jones.
The pair started with
developing training products
for pro teams that used augmented reality
so athletes could practice with both
real and virtual teammates.
Now. they wanna bring that
experience to a wider audience.
Football is such a unique
game because it's something
that you can enjoy and
watch and spend time
with your family doing,
but to get on that field
and see it from the player's perspective
and actually play it,
I do think you'll gain
a deeper appreciation of what goes into
what you see on TVs on Sundays,
and that's something that
obviously as two former players
we're passionate about.
We kinda had this vision of
"Man, this technology was
going to be the future, right,
and how do we find our space in that?"
We're both former athletes,
so we have a specific
way of looking at it,
and we felt like there was
a way for us to kinda create
an experience that everybody
could participate in
from athletes, to coaches,
to front offices, to fans.
And in my demo,
the immersion factor was believable.
It felt like I was actually taking a snap
at Acrisure Stadium.
The sounds of players running at me
made me afraid to hold
onto the ball for too long.
It wasn't perfect, however.
While fans of teams might recognize
their offensive line by their numbers,
their faces aren't as realistic,
and occasionally you'll see some players
defy some laws of physics.
But even when things went
wrong, the game still felt fun.
You see the guy to the slot right here,
number three, again?
He's gonna break inside in the middle.
Let's try to hit him in
the middle when he breaks.
Oh my god.
Oh, you got the wrong hand?
Uh oh.
With a left-handed touchdown?
"NFL Pro Era" is not the first
American football simulator
to be created in a VR headset.
There have been arcade-like games
like "2MD" and "MVP Football,"
as well as what is essentially
immersive advertising
from Gatorade that
features Peyton Manning.
Before we get you back out there,
we need to talk about hydration.
But importantly, it's the first to have
the official license with the NFL,
and it's the first NFL
branded video game of any kind
outside of "Madden" to debut since 2004.
I think the NFL, you
know, just to be clear,
they are the most powerful
sports league in the world,
and I think for them
it's about making sure
that if they're going into
any partnership with someone
it brings value to their
fans and to the league.
And when you sit, even
people who work for the NFL
on the 50 yard line of the Ravens stadium,
or the Eagles stadium
and on the Giants stadium
are like, "Wait, I even realized
that I've never been in this position."
I think when that started to
circulate around the league
and they started to see
how this could potentially
change their fans' experience,
they immediately saw the value.
Traditionally, fans of the NFL
have been able to have
this experience already
through the "Madden" video game,
a yearly release that
sells millions of copies
despite lackluster reviews
over the last five years.
"Madden," from publisher
EA, has the advantage
of launching on all the
major gaming consoles
as well as for PC and mobile devices.
Sales for StatusPRO,
however, will be limited
to only owners of
virtual reality headsets.
We don't know exactly
if VR is ready per se.
That's not something we can determine,
but what we know is we
can bring an experience
that your fans have never had.
And our goal and our hope is
to be one of the experiences
that continues to contribute
to the upward tick of VR
and make it more ubiquitous.
All right.
Let's roll.
This is 2369 warm up, take one.
Mark.
Ah! Okay.
Whenever you are ready.
All right.
Outside of the draw of
major sports leagues,
like the NFL, one area that is bringing
a larger and more diverse
group of users to VR
has been fitness.
This is 236900 bagatali
and your warm up is in New Zealand.
What's up, athlete? I'm Coach Leanne.
Welcome to Sweat Symphony.
Shake everything out.
At first glance, this might sound like
the start of any instructor-led workout.
But from inside a headset,
it feels more like a mixture
of a Peloton class and "Guitar Hero."
"Supernatural" was essentially created
by two people who hated working out
and wanted to find a
way to make working out
something that was actually
fun instead of dreadful.
This is Leanne Pedante.
She's the head of fitness
for "Supernatural,"
a VR app that feels more
like a fitness studio
than a traditional game.
You put on this headset
and you're transported
to a beautiful immersive location,
like a Galapagos Island or
The Great Wall of China,
and you're smashing or boxing to targets
that are flying at you to
music that you know and love
while being coached by a coach like me,
who is guiding you through the experience
and reminding you what an
amazing athlete that you are.
"Supernatural's" also structured
more like a fitness studio.
You buy a membership
for around $20 a month,
and you can choose from a list of workouts
like boxing, flow, meditate, and stretch,
and new workouts are added every day.
Launching in the spring of
2020, the app gained popularity
as many people were searching
for ways to work out
while under lockdown,
and notably people who didn't
traditionally visit gyms.
Myself, I've been a "Supernatural" athlete
for just over a year now.
Fitness presents a lot of
barriers for a lot of people.
A lot of people feel left out of fitness
or they feel unwelcome in gyms,
and "Supernatural" has
the most diverse community
of users and members that
I've ever seen in my career.
We have members from their
20s to their 80s and 90s.
We have members who
are using this to train
for ambitious sports, and we have members
who have never worked
out before in their life
and are doing it for the very first time.
Growing and expanding that user base,
especially to an older and
more gender diverse audience,
is incredibly important to companies
hoping to profit in the metaverse.
On October 28th, 2021,
Facebook rebranded as Meta.
The next day, it announced plans to buy
"Supernatural's" studio within
for a reported $400 million.
But in July of 2022, the FTC
sued to block that purchase
saying Meta is trying to buy its way
into a monopoly over virtual reality.
In a statement, Meta
claimed their purchase
would only benefit the industry
saying attempting to bar Meta
for making acquisitions
at all benefits no one,
especially if the goal is to encourage
innovation and competition.
While many studios are
hard at work to find
what could be the killer app
when it comes to virtual reality,
the other question that remains is if
this new spatial internet
does materialize,
how will companies profit from it?
And that leads to the
bigger existential questions
around the intimate, some say invasive,
role big tech companies like Meta
and products like Facebook
play in our lives.
Right now, there are a
lot of companies that work
under a surveillance capitalism model.
It's not the greatest word,
but it kind of accurately
describes the fact that the
people who were once consumers
are actually the product
and their data gets sold
to businesses who then
advertise products to them,
and that's the economic engine.
This advertising business is massive.
In 2021, Meta brought in
$116 billion in revenue
and $57 billion in profit from online ads.
In the past, Facebook has
drawn blistering criticism
from across the private sector
and government regulators
about its collection and role
in spreading disinformation
and hate speech.
And devices that would allow
you to access digital worlds
also have the ability to
access more data about you,
your location, your interests,
and down the line, potentially
even your emotions.
So a lot of concern has been put into
can we create a healthy
economic model in a metaverse
that isn't requiring advertising?
And so the reality is since
the metaverse is really
just a mirror of physical society
by digital means and
the spectrum in between,
you can take any way
that you can make money
in the physical world and
you can just do it digitally.
Some of the biggest sports
leagues in the world
are already testing this theory,
starting with maybe the most obvious
selling tickets to virtual games.
Jaylen Brown took it in.
That's a three from Al Horford.
The new era of technology
with the metaverse AR, VR
is really just the latest
chapter in an effort
the NBA has been making for years,
which is how to connect
the game with fans,
and more fans then can fit in the arena.
This is Jen Chun,
head of partnerships for the NBA,
who have been an early
adopter of VR technology.
Back in 2015, the league was capturing
a VR courtside experience,
at a time when 360 cameras were still
held together with tape.
The actual capture technology
of the cameras has improved,
but I think also it's the experiences
around where you find those games.
So for example, this last season,
in addition to being able
to go into "Horizon Worlds"
to actually see a game in VR,
you could experience what
we built called NBA Lane
which celebrated our 75th anniversary.
So instead of just being
able to watch the game,
you could go into the
virtual amusement park
and actually yourself participate
in slam dunk competitions,
firing t-shirt cannons,
and walking around in VR with your friend
or other NBA fans.
This last season,
the Brooklyn Nets and
the YES Network released
what they called the netaverse,
a glimpse at what is possible
in the future of viewing sports.
While far from perfect,
you could view the game from
any perspective on the court.
And just like going to
a game in real life,
proponents of a digital economy believe
you'll be inclined to
purchase merchandise,
maybe a virtual hat or
jersey for your favorite team
that your digital avatar can wear.
The NBA has also experimented
in the NFT market
with digital trading
cards based on highlights.
But I think what it really comes down to
is the emotional attachment
that fans have to the games,
to particular moments in the games,
and so to give fans the
opportunity to have a sense
of ownership of certain
moments in the games
is an incredible connection
directly to the fan.
See what we got here.
Door number two.
It's unclear whether
this emotional connection
to teams or players is enough to create
real digital values in these spaces.
While Top Shot cards
gained popularity early,
their sales have since
declined drastically.
But for the NBA, creating
these digital experiences
in merchandise are more testing grounds
for how future consumers may behave.
Innovation has to have a
lean forward, bold, testing,
take that first step mentality to it.
It's a build it, they will
come kind of attitude,
but I think it's most important for us
to continue to make sure that
fans can connect to the NBA.
After all, leagues like the NBA or NFL
are slow to change,
especially when it comes
to how we watch.
Sports commands some of the largest
media rights deals in the
world, and changing them,
even to popular streaming
sites, has been a slow process.
But for Meta, they have high
ambitions for how future fans
will engage with sports.
The ideal scenario for me is
that sports gets to a point
where in order to truly experience
the fandom of the league
you're most passionate about,
or the team you're most passionate about,
you have to do it under quest.
The history of new
technology being rolled out
certainly supports sports
helping drive audiences.
We saw it with Fox
becoming a major network
by going out and acquiring NFL rights.
We saw direct TV go
after NFL rights as well
in order to get audiences
to pay for their products.
Football?
Up to 13 NFL games every
Sunday if you want 'em.
I love you.
I know, sir.
What we're excited to
see with VR in the future
is the ability for this to become a part
of your common behavior,
the best way that you
could watch, express,
and really engage around
a live sports event.
But as Ben Grossmamn explains,
having the metaverse,
whether that's an AR or VR experience,
be the primary way we consume sports
from a technical perspective
is still a long way off.
Sports is fundamentally
one of the few things
left in society that is very dependent
on the power of live.
Latency, the time it takes between
I did something and I received
input in the metaverse
is extremely critical and very difficult.
In sports, it's the difference
between win and loss,
and in the metaverse
it's one of the hardest
things to achieve.
We're gonna take things
up a level and talk
about defense and footwork.
Fists in front of your face.
The metaverse can feel fun at times,
but also frustrating and empty.
The idea of watching something
inside of it with friends
often still requires a
lot of time and effort,
and there's almost
always some kind of bugs
in the experience.
I think for people who
are trying to tackle
sports specifically in the metaverse,
the rewards that are on the
table are pretty significant.
There's a lot of money in that area,
and there's a lot of complexity,
and the solutions to those
problems are pretty ubiquitous.
They apply to so many other things.
If you can solve the problems in sports,
well, then you can work
backwards from that.
You can do movies and
television type content.
You could also get into education
and a million other things.
It is an argument to be made
that you find those things
that have the biggest
economic opportunity,
you work at solving those problems,
and then you use those
solutions to kind of go after
the things that have less treasure
at the end of that hunt, so to speak,
and I think sports is
one of those sectors.